[Musique]
trois cent mille personnes aux 24 heures
du mans quelques milliers seulement
rassembler sur les bords de la seine
mais dans un bus résolument opposé dans
la vie que voulez vous il ya du pour et
du contre mais on ou l'automobile n'est
sûrement pas la solution pour la
circulation urbaine et je le souligne
bien précis que la chaîne robert
ce qu'on demande c'est une interdiction
progressive donc de la circulation
urbaine à paris qu'est ce que vous
faites dans cette manifestation
cette manifestation parce que nous
sommes contre la voie sur berge et que
vous allez prouver là c'est une longue
marche
c'est une longue marche nous allons
prouver que tout ce qui est fait est
absurde que faire une voie express rive
gauche
en trente ans les berges c'est amener
davantage de voitures individuelles
alors qu'il y en a déjà de trop à paris
c'est pas la solution des solutions
l'autre solution c'est que les voitures
soient souterraine mais qu'on nous garde
les berges alors sur ses berges faire au
poète les manifestants ont planté un
arbre symbolique un sapin peut-être
parce qu'aucun règlement n'interdit de
croire au père noël
[Musique]